appell an die bevölkerung um die
ausbreitung des corona virus einzudämmen
brauchen wir jeden einzelnen sagte der
gesundheitsminister
in nordrhein westfalen gibt es zwei
todesfälle für die wirtschaft beschließt
die bundesregierung hilfen
sport vor leeren rängen
bundesliga-duelle könnten wegen des
corona virus zu geisterspielen werden
und hilfe für flüchtlingskinder
deutschland minderjährige aus
griechischen lagern aufnehmen wenn
andere eu länder mitziehen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den sport haben doch von mir
die experten haben es vorausgesagt es
wird auch hierzulande tote durch das
corona virus geben
am nachmittag kam dann die nachricht der
ersten beiden fälle in deutschland eine
89 jährige aus essen und ein 78 jähriger
aus heinsberg bei mönchengladbach sind
an den folgen der viruserkrankung
gestorben
bei einer halben stunde hat der landrat
des kreises heinsberg auf einer
pressekonferenz details bekanntgegeben
und peter böhme ist für uns vor ort
peter das hat der landrat sagen können
ja der landrat hat eben gesagt das kann
ja schon alles ist ein 78-jähriger mann
der heute hier um 14 uhr verstorben ist
der mann hatte vorerkrankungen hatte
diabetes er herzprobleme
er hat sich letzten freitag ins
krankenhaus begeben und eben über fieber
und husten geklagt es heute leider
verstorben
der landrat hat auch gesagt das ist eben
momentan 323 fälle hier gibt in
heinsberg 15 davon sind im krankenhaus
stationär aufgenommen
fünf davon liegen auf intensiv der
landrat warnte aber auch vor hysterie
die sei für gefährlicher als eben die
eigentlichen gefahren vor ort dankeschön
nach heinz peter böhme also eine oder
beide todesfälle aus der risikogruppe
der älteren die zahl der infizierten in
deutschland steigt weiter mittlerweile
sind es 1000 112 menschen eindringlich
hat gesundheitsminister sparen heute an
alle appelliert jeder einzelne könne
dazu beitragen den virus den ausbruch
des virus zu bremsen und damit eben
ältere und vor erkrankte zu schützen
konkret ruft er dazu auf weniger zu
reisen zu hause zu arbeiten wenn möglich
menschen über 60 sollten sich gegen
pneumokokken impfen lassen und sparen
bekräftigt seine empfehlungen
veranstaltungen mit mehr als 1000
teilnehmern abzusagen britta spiekermann
berichtet aufklären und keine
nicht verbreiten der gesundheitsminister
begleitet vom chef geologen der charité
und dem chef des robert-koch-instituts
spanien fehlt die absage von
veranstaltungen mit mehr als 1000
teilnehmern alles aus über 1000 sollte
angesichts der lage und dem
übergeordneten ziele zu verlangsamen
aus unserer sicht grundsätzlich nicht
stattfinden den nächsten wochen und
monaten und alles unter 1000 braucht
trotzdem weiterhin die individuelle
betrachtung was genau ist denn da
eigentlich für ein infektionsrisiko dann
dann auch da jens spahn kann die absage
von veranstaltungen nicht anordnen
jede lokale behörde entscheidet selbst
nach einer risikoabschätzung geschützt
werden müssten besonders ältere menschen
vor allem die über 65-jährigen ganz
besonders die über 80-jährigen
noch sind die meisten infizierten in
deutschland unter 50 was die niedrige
todesrate erklärt nach allem was wir
wissen verläuft diese krankheit die wir
kobik 19 nennen in vier von fünf fällen
mild das bedeutet aber auch gleichzeitig
das bei jedem fünften patienten schwerer
verläuft so schwer dass die menschen
auch ins krankenhaus müssen die oberste
maxime die ausbreitung verlangsamen um
zeit zu gewinnen damit das
gesundheitssystem nicht heillos
überfordert wird ein impfstoff ist noch
nicht in sicht professor osten von der
charité prognostiziert nicht nur wochen
sondern monate mit dem virus und
empfiehlt die aufstockung von
intensivbetten positiv sei dass man
schon früh tests durchgeführt habe wir
haben das ganze auch sehr früh erkannt
bei uns im land und das ist sicherlich
auch eine eine botschaft aus der
forschung man sagen kann wir sind hier
bei uns in deutschland einfach vorne
dran was die diagnostik angeht was den
nachweis angeht das corona virus eine
große aufgabe für den
gesundheitsminister für die gesellschaft
für jeden einzelnen
um die arztpraxen zu entlasten gelten ab
sofort einfache regeln für
krankschreibungen erkältete patienten
ohne konkreten corona verdacht können
nach telefonischer rücksprache mit dem
arzt eine
arbeitsunfähigkeitsbescheinigung für bis
zu sieben tage bekommen
sie müssen dafür nicht in die praxis
dass haben kassen ärzte und
krankenkassen beschlossen
das gilt zunächst für vier wochen in
brandenburg stehen nach einem corona
verdachtsfall an einer schule mit zwei
angeschlossenen wright internaten etwa
4000 menschen unter häuslicher
quarantäne
betroffen sind schüler lehrer und
verwaltungsmitarbeiter in der region
neustadt an der dosse sowie
internatsschüler aus ganz deutschland
hintergrund ist ein treffen in der
vergangenen woche an dem lehrer der
schule teilgenommen hatten
dort war auch eine frau aus berlin bei
der später eine infektion mit dem virus
nachgewiesen wurde
auch die wirtschaftlichen folgen von
corona sind immens und treffen fast alle
branchen deshalb hat die große koalition
jetzt hilfsmaßnahmen beschlossen
stichwort kurzarbeitergeld ab april
können angeschlagene unternehmen ist
leichter beantragen müssten also
angestellte nicht gleich entlassen wenn
aufträge wegbrechen
außerdem sollen firmen in not
unkompliziert an kredite kommen und
zusätzliche investitionen sind geplant
rund 12,4 milliarden euro in den
nächsten vier jahren etwa für
verkehrsprojekte patricia video die
firma transgourmet aus mainz ist eine
große catering-firma da viele größere
veranstaltungen nicht mehr stattfinden
der umsatz einzubrechen
die ersten aufträge wurden bereits
storniert das ist ganz einfach so dass
für hotellerie und catering beliefern
und acht bis zehn prozent einbußen haben
durch dieses carola währung
es sind vor allem das hotel und
gaststättengewerbe sowie die
touristikbranche die betroffen sind auch
der bdi rechnet mit massiven einbußen
in einigen branchen sind die
absatzrückgänge existenzgefährdend in
anderen sind es aber produktionsausfälle
und die gleichzeitigkeit dieser effekte
ist neu unternehmerisches handeln
alleine können das nicht ausgleichen
die koalition hat daher hilfen für die
betroffenen firmen beschlossen wir haben
möglichkeiten der bundesagentur
verarbeiten mittel dann zur verfügung zu
stellen um kurzarbeit zu unterstützen
jetzt werden die voraussetzung
erleichtert um diese förderung zu
bekommen wir werden auch die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge für die
unternehmen übernehmen in dieser
überbrückungszeit die grünen begrüßen
die maßnahmen der regierung fordern die
staatlichen gelder aber sinnvoll zu
nutzen insofern schlagen wir ein
investitionsprogramm speziell für diese
gewerbe vor die jetzt die restaurants
und die hotels dann von der
energetischen sanierung bis zum
austausch der heizung bis zur
digitalisierung fit und flott machen
können es sei eine situation wie sie sie
noch nie erlebt hätten sagt auch die
messe baufirma zwei aufträge für 12
millionen euro wurden abgesagt sie
hoffen dass die regierung wirklich wie
versprochen alles tun wird um die
wirtschaft zu stabilisieren
auch die börsen reagierten weltweit mit
verlusten der deutsche aktienindex ist
so deutlich eingebrochen wie seit 18
jahren nicht mehr
von bethmann in frankfurt an der börse
wie dramatisch ist die situation ja
jetzt wird es tatsächlich immer
brenzliger nicht nur corona am morgen
stürzten zusätzlich noch die preise für
das rohöl um sage und schreibe 30
prozent ab der größte einbruch seit 30
jahren grund dafür ein preiskrieg
zwischen saudi arabien und russland
was verbraucher und industrie ja
eigentlich freuen sollte sport billiges
öl wird in dieser situation wo die
weltwirtschaft bereits schwer
angeschlagen ist zum bedenklichen symbol
der schwäche corona und der crash am
ölmarkt zusammen also führt zum
ausverkauf hier in frankfurt verliert
der dax heute über 900 punkte oder fast
8 prozent nachdem der handel sogar
unterbrochen wurde gibt der dow jones
index an der wall street derzeit knapp
sieben prozent nach auch der index der
führenden europäischen aktien mit mehr
als acht prozent im minus und das
italienische leitbarometer büßt sogar
elf prozent ein schwarzer montag also an
den börsen weltweit die größte sorge
gilt nun den
franken was wenn unternehmen in der
krise ihre kredite nicht mehr
zurückzahlen können geraten dann auch
die geldhäuser wieder in eine
gefährliche schieflage
viele fragen auf dem dankeschön nach
frankfurt frank widmann
wie kommen ärzte mit der korona krise
klar wie die wirtschaft dazu gleich noch
mehr im anschluss in wiso und immer die
letzten entwicklungen zur ausbreitung
des virus bei uns auf heute.de im live
blog zu einem anderen wichtigen thema
der lage der flüchtlinge auf den
griechischen inseln seit wochen bietet
ein bündnis deutscher kommunen an
mehrere hundert kinder und jugendliche
aus den flüchtlingslagern aufzunehmen
bisher hat die regierung das abgelehnt
jetzt schlägt sie vor wenn andere eu
staaten mitmachen sollen insgesamt 1500
minderjährige aufgenommen werden
christiane hübscher berichtet ein paar
der flüchtlingskinder die in lagern wie
diesem auf lesbos leben dürfen
vielleicht nach deutschland kommen aber
nur wenn sie schwer krank sind oder aber
unbegleitet und jünger als 14
das sind die bedingungen die die große
koalition letzten acht aufgestellt hat
im beschlusspapier ein vages versprechen
wir wollen griechenland bei der
schwierigen humanitären lage von etwa
1000 bis 1500 kindern auf den
griechischen inseln unterstützen
es gehe um das prinzip humanität und
ordnung so sagt es die bundeskanzlerin
dass kinder die krank sind die besonders
verwundbar sind die unbegleitet sind die
in einer schwierigen situation sind
hilfe gegeben werden muss das kann
griechenland nicht alleine bewältigen
und deshalb 40 deutschland in einer
koalition der willigen mit einem
angemessenen anteil auch beteiligen
eine echte koalition der willigen auf eu
ebene aber gibt es bisher nicht nur
erste signale anderer staaten und
angemessener deutsche anteil was wäre
das wie schnell all das ist längst nicht
geklärt
konkret wird das erst im lauf der woche
weil innenminister horst seehofer
verhandelt frankreich ist glaube ich mit
400 dabei und ungefähr daran werden wir
uns auch messen
deutschland hätte gut alleine 5000
kinder aufnehmen können das wäre für
unser großes land kein problem weder
wirtschaftlich noch von den
unterbringungsmöglichkeiten die ganz
viele städte in unserem land angeboten
haben
laut hilfsorganisationen sollen es
14.000 kinder sein die auf allen
griechischen inseln auf hilfe warten
und auch an der landgrenze zwischen
griechenland und der türkei bleibt die
situation der flüchtlinge kritisch
tausende harren dort aus in der hoffnung
in die eu zu gelangen
sie waren gekommen nachdem der türkische
präsident erdogan vor anderthalb wochen
die tore zur eu für offen erklärt hatte
im moment spricht erdogan in brüssel mit
eu ratspräsidenten shell und
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen und
anne gellinek uns in brüssel eine die
türkei beschuldigt die eu zusagen aus
dem flüchtlings abkommen nicht
einzuhalten
die eu sagt sie lasse sich von erdogan
nicht erpressen kann dieses gespräch
heute die wogen glätten
nein danach sieht es noch nicht aus die
begrüßung des türkischen präsidenten
durch die spitzen der eu viel
einigermaßen frostig aus eu
ratspräsident michelle und
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
waren den ganzen tag über bemüht die
erwartungen an dieses treffen möglichst
herunterzufahren
die eu ist immer noch sauer auf erdogan
weil er migranten benutzt hat als
druckmittel gegen die europäische union
an der europäischen außengrenzen und sie
erwartet vom türkischen präsidenten dass
er sich heute abend ganz klar zu den
vereinbarungen zu den vereinbarungen des
eu flüchtlings paktes bekennt erdogan
dagegen will mehr geld für die syrischen
flüchtlinge in der türkei
er will militärhilfe für syrien und visa
erleichterungen für seine bürger zu all
dem wird es heute nicht kommen sondern
die eu ließ im vorfeld durchblicken dass
es wahrscheinlich nur der anfang eines
dialogs sein könnte heute abend der dann
am ende auf dem eu gipfel ende des
monats vielleicht dazu führen könnte
dass noch einmal über den pakt
debattiert wird das gäbe auch den eu
mitgliedstaaten die möglichkeit eine
gemeinsame haltung zu dem verhältnis zur
türkei zu finden
dankeschön für diese informationen aus
brüssel an die klinik
lange haben die hinterbliebenen gewartet
heute club sechs jahre nach dem abschuss
von flug im h 17 hat in den niederlanden
der prozess begonnen
angeklagt sind drei russen und ein
ukraine
die maschine der manege er war 2014 auf
dem weg von amsterdam nach kuala lumpur
über umkämpften gebiet in der ost
ukraine abgeschossen worden
dabei kamen alle 228 menschen an bord
ums leben die meisten waren niederländer
die filmbranche hat einen ihrer
wandlungsfähigsten charakterdarsteller
verloren den schweden max von sido mit
90 jahren ist er in paris gestorben von
sido filmte bis ins hohe alter zuletzt
auch in großen blockbuster produktionen
große regisseure arbeitet mit ihm darf
man scorsese woody allen spielberg
berühmt hatte ihn 1973 der exorzist
gemacht dämonisch spielte wieder da
einen priester der teufelsaustreibungen
folgt dubiose überweisungen in
millionenhöhe korruptionsvorwürfe längst
überschatten sie das sogenannte
sommermärchen die fußball wm 2006 in
deutschland
jetzt soll ein schweizer gericht licht
ins dunkel bringen angeklagt sind die ex
dfb präsident zwanziger und niersbach
und der frühere dfb generalsekretär
schmitt
das verfahren gegen den damaligen wm
organisationschef beckenbauer wurde aus
gesundheitsgründen abgetrennt saar
attacke über den beginn des prozesses
die schweizer justiz will klären was bis
heute im unklaren ist war die wm 2006
das deutsche sommermärchen gekauft und
wenn ja von wem aus der anklageschrift
die dem zdf vorliegt geht hervor dass
sich beckenbauer im jahr 2002 6 7
millionen euro vom ehemaligen adidas
chef louis dreyfus li und kurz darauf
insgesamt 6,7 millionen euro an
verschiedene firmen des fifa funktionär
bin hammam überwies wieso das konnten
die schweizer in fünf jahren
ermittlungen nicht aufklären
auch gelang es ihnen wieder beckenbauer
noch bin hammam den prozess zu machen
beckenbauer sei zu krank bin hammam in
katar nicht greifbar aber sie haben die
möglichen gehilfen angeklagt denn die
anklageschrift zeigt dass beckenbauer
die dfb-funktionäre niersbach zwanziger
und schmidt mit ins boot geholt haben
soll damit der dfb beckenbauer 6,7
millionen euro schuld begleicht und der
plan ging auf denn der dfb bubis exakt
diese summe über die fifa und den
mitangeklagten urs linsi an beckenbauers
geldgeber louis dreyfus diesen möglichen
betrug in höhe von 6,7 millionen euro zu
lasten des dfb haben die schweizer
angeklagt bis ende april muss ein urteil
vorliegen sonst ist alles verjährt und
die vier angeklagten könnten niemals
bestraft werden aber nach dem
prozessauftakt heute ist auch klar dass
das möglich ist denn die richter drücken
ordentlich aufs tempo und in der schweiz
anders als in deutschland ist es
durchaus üblich dass komplexe
wirtschaftsstrafverfahren wie dieses
innerhalb weniger tage dann auch zu
einem urteil führen können wir gespannt
sein was war noch aus der schweiz kommt
aber auch der fußball steht im moment
ganz im zeichen des corona wäre es
absolut stichwort geisterspiele
jetzt steht fest in der champions league
da steht leipzig morgen abend zu hause
vor vollem haus dortmund aber einen tag
später in paris vor leeren rängen
unklarheit dagegen in der
fußball-bundesliga findet
mönchengladbach kölner mittwoch vor
leeren tribünen stadt die gladbacher
gesundheitsbehörden wollen morgen ihre
entscheidung zum nachholspiel
bekanntgeben in der liga herrscht
unsicherheit
wir haben dann gerade konsequent
inkonsequent in vielerlei hinsicht würde
mir wünschen dass man irgend einem eine
klare ansage gemacht und das tut aber
keiner
vielleicht auch nicht so einfach ist das
kann ja natürlich nachvollziehen
dfl-geschäftsführer seifert geht davon
aus dass spätestens kommendes wochenende
erste bundesliga spiele ohne publikum
stattfinden werden
wir würden am liebsten schon nächsten
spieltag mit zuschauern spielen
das ist aber leider nicht realistisch
wir haben entschieden dass der spieltag
stattfindet rein sportlich mit wie
vielen zuschauern und ob ohne das ist
eine entscheidung die die behörden
treffen müssen die vereine pochen auf
eine einheitliche regelung finde schon
dass es dann verbleiben was in der
bundesliga dass man versuchen muss für
alle eine einheitliche lösung zu finden
weil es einfach daran wettbewerb ist der
dass eine ergebnis im staate beeinflusst
auch das die situation ist anderen
verein zum anderen stadion in anderen
sportarten in denen eintrittsgelder eine
wichtige einnahmequelle sind gibt es
existenzielle sorgen angesichts
drohender geisterspiele
fußball-bundesligist fc augsburg trennt
sich von trainer martin schmidt
begründung die schlechte bilanz von nur
vier punkten aus neun begegnungen
ein nachfolger steht noch nicht fest zur
tournee der skispringer in norwegen da
musste er gestern in oslo der welt cup
einzel wettbewerb der männer abgesagt
werden der wurde nun heute in
lillehammer ausgetragen ja und da siegte
vor wenigen minuten der slowene peter
putz mit hauchdünnem vorsprung vor zwei
deutschen springern markus eisenbichler
und stephan leyhe karl berger kam nur
auf rang 19 und verlor damit weitere
punkte auf den gesamtführenden stefan
kraft aus österreich das was von mir
dankeschön gisela heißt das tief das uns
morgen viel regen und wind bringt sonne
ist mangelware einzelheiten gleich von
katja roll over das heute journal um 10
vor 10 mit claus kleber haben sie noch
einen schönen abend und bis morgen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren tief gisela
liegt heute abend über den britischen
inseln und es überquert uns morgen mit
seinem regenband von west nach ost und
bringt zum teil 20 bis 30 liter regen
pro quadratmeter mit das wird also die
hochwassersituation in einigen bächen
und flüssen wieder verschärfen das mit
dem regen geht schon heute nacht los und
dem sauerland ist doch etwas schnee beim
regen dabei am alpenrand kann es noch
letzte schauer geben sonst aber es ist
im osten häufig klar
dort sinken die temperaturen deswegen
auf +3 bis -2 grad es kann also auch mal
glatt sein
anders sieht es unter den regenwolken
aus da bleibt es milder bei 6 bis 4 grad
und morgen liegen die temperaturen im
osten und in bayern bei 6 bis 8 grad
sonst werden zweistellige 10 bis 14 grad
erreicht
schon am vormittag ziehen die
regenwolken weiter nach osten anfänglich
ist hier und dann etwas schnee dabei im
thüringer wald im erzgebirge auch im
schwarzwald und eine chance auf sonne
haben sie hier zwischen dem spreewald
und dem oberpfälzer wald am nachmittag
ist es damit vorbei
dann regnet es auch im osten und die
schneefallgrenze kommt drauf es gestellt
also überall regen bei einem starken bis
stürmischen wind und an der nordsee sind
auch sturmböen möglich sehr wechselhaft
geht es dann in den nächsten tagen
weiter am donnerstag gibt es im südosten
bis 20 grad